hello and welcome to this video mateo 02
okay no interest for any form of bank
combat or whatever wow we should be to
that feels a bit stodgy if you ask me so
let's see can I do this let me give me
Bishop air before he gets to see three
now I will probably get this official
maybe you place before something but
hmm kind of time out now I mean why not
just Knight c3 or something that that
cannot be bad for what he is very well
developed and I mean okay i get the
bishop but what's the what's the deal
yeah so he went for this no white is ok
yeah this development is fine so it
should be it should be young completely
ok is he trying some weird stuff here
from using the quick development not
show him I can perform yeah I stuff like
that I kind of wondered my queen doesn't
have all that many squares yeah yeah
before choice tricky yeah a five would
stop before but looks a little bit a
little bit strange I think I still do it
I'm then put on the dark squares here so
it feels it feels I should be ok let's
see 66 those kind of moves
night before maybe as an interesting but
ok county 25 probably not
so what's the plan okay he comes up with
a plan night to d3 is his idea and okay
cannot really prevent that I can go
Bishop f5 maybe Bishop d3 I put it back
and by the way I'm interesting I cannot
move this is 697 is always hanging night
before but being something with his
seven always hangs there here I'm going
back but now that 93 is out of the
picture not to move that ahead on the
radar here at all but interesting 33
Queen 87 so probably covered this so
that i can go to e 7 a-7 hey I made him
a turn you did a good job here using his
using a spider development and I'll see
five probably not see five okay I was
really expecting to go see five if I go
b6 to stop c 5 well but before I didn't
mind before that much really don't i
have control over a 1 so he cannot
simply cannot play okay one and get me
on the FL look c 2 h or maybe
what's going on here I don't get this
might be five
is that good for wine
I simply didn't expect the moves i'm not
saying it's bad i mean i just wonder
okay so he wants to go to c6 but that
makes a lot of sense but hmm maybe this
is an annoying Pena right this is a bit
of an annoying pin he doesn't have he
doesn't have queen bee to as a natural
way of breaking it f5 okay this one I'm
a blundering stuff there on f7 or so hmm
maybe I am like takes takes Queen f2 we
have that that's really possible hmm and
he might have some other ideas if i take
bishop jinx somehow i feel like there's
some tech tech it looks a little bit
shaky invites position if i take there
and then look c5 that's maybe an idea he
cannot take right B takes Winston
Winston might it's a temple and I have
rook c8 maybe next exploiting this pin
maybe efore
ok so here right Thank maybe look
everyone I just know where that takes
you from Kim
night Matt come to d5 here right time
morning I should don't have a good idea
35 maybe 96 maybe coming oh ah whoa that
was a nice one that is a nice shot I
didn't see that shot at all ah that's a
full/queen yeah oh my god oh god wow
you're resigning is not such a bad idea
I still have caught some chicks hey III
doesn't do anything how disappointing I
really thought I was getting somewhere
but then I blend the Queen yeah I don't
know like I screw up those positions
myself all the time so I'm continuing it
a little bit but probably nothing will
come of it I can actually could have
taken at home but okay so
check check check check check check
commissioned me to draw oh my goodness
pook oh my god yeah note from for those
who see I'm playing I was down on time
the whole the whole time so whatever and
what do we have here I want to I really
want to understand this a little bit
better ok so here is not that much to to
check that was really interesting I was
thinking c5 here but maybe this is not a
good idea this I mean the develop the
development looks look somewhat
dangerous have it probably there is
nothing the engine confirms that there's
nothing at least short-term yeah I felt
I should be quite ok orally e6 was given
by the engine but I'm interested in this
position type here this is this I went
here I really thought this would be
quite nice but you know looks it too we
can already play that as given by the
engine and I simply did not spot the
distress by Queen I probably would have
blundered the Queen right here somehow I
didn't spot this idea and this also
probably means that why this bad i am if
I have to do this kind of weird move
center mercury has no
yeah so that that wasn't a good idea
this whole thing Queen a 3 is roughly
equal not as simply as simply did not
see that my queen is in danger
absolutely not now just like no I had
absolutely no worry in the world okay
yeah when as I said I mean I'm screwing
up those kind of positions all the time
I continued and yes I'm somehow somewhat
ended in a draw cat in all the scramble
we had made in one but okay I both did
there anytime check check check check
clicker ridiculous oh my god of all the
porns really strange anyway I hope you
got something out of it thanks for
watching